well good afternoon everyone
foreign
as always I'm delighted to welcome you
back to the state department of the
United States and
it is
a great pleasure to continue our ongoing
collaboration on so many issues that
join our countries together
um as is fitting
for such a close friend and Ally the
discussion we had today touched on an
incredibly wide range of critically
important issues that are having a real
impact on the lives of our our citizens
Canadians and Americans alike as well as
uh people across the globe we of course
discussed our United response
to President Putin's war in Ukraine
including
his latest Shameless effort
to legitimize his attempted land grab in
Ukraine
no one is fooled by what Moscow has done
the world saw the way Russia conducted
these so-called referendum
with Russian occupation forces going
door to door enforcing Ukrainian
citizens to cast their ballots at
gunpoint
the entire process around the Sham
referenda was a complete farce
the United States does not
and will never recognize any of the
kremlin's claims to sovereignty over
parts of Ukraine that it's seized by
force
and not reports to incorporate into
Russia
as I said last week at the United
Nations security Council this territory
is and will remain Ukrainian
and Ukraine has every right to defend
its land to defend its people
and to take back the territory that
Russia has seized from it
Canada and the United States like so
many nations around the world
see eye to eye on this
these are just the latest in a long line
of actions by Russia since it launched
this war of aggression against Ukraine
that violate international law
that flout the principles of sovereignty
and territorial Integrity which
underpinned the entire International
order so necessary to keeping peace and
security around the world
uh and all of this
shows the kremlin's utter contempt for
the rights
and the will of the Ukrainian people
I also made clear that when Russia made
this move
the United States and our allies and
partners would impose Swift and severe
costs on individuals and entities inside
and outside of Russia
that provide political or economic
support to Illegal attempts to change
the status of Ukrainian territory today
we've done just that in coordination
with the European Union and Canada is
taking similar steps as well
uh we're also wishing a clear warning
supported by G7 leaders
we will hold to account
any individual entity or country that
provides political or economic support
for President Putin's illegal attempts
to change the status of Ukrainian
territory
support of this commitment the
Departments of the treasury and commerce
are releasing new guidance on heightened
sanctions and Export control risks for
entities and individuals inside and
outside of Russia that support in any
way the Kremlin sham referenda purported
annexation and occupation of parts of
Ukraine
um we're also taking action today at the
United Nations security Council to hold
Russia accountable for the Sham
referendum and the purported annexations
if Russia blocks the security Council
from carrying out its responsibilities
we'll ask the UN General Assembly where
every country has a vote to make clear
that it's unacceptable to redraw borders
by force
every country has a stake in condemning
these steps
as U.N Secretary General guterres said
this week and I quote
the United Nations Charter is clear
any annexation of a state's territory by
another state resulting from the threat
or use of force is a violation of the
principles of the United Nations Charter
and international law
the United States Canada and our other
allies and partners will continue to
assist Ukraine in the fight to defend
its territory against Russian aggression
with new security assistance that we
announced just this week
the United States has now committed
approximately 16.9 billion dollars in
security assistance to Ukraine going
back to January 2021.
um in our meeting the foreign minister
and I discussed ways to continue
supporting Ukraine and our European
allies as they prepare for a difficult
Venture ahead
our commitment to Ukraine's sovereignty
its independence its territorial
Integrity is steadfast
the United States and Canada will also
continue to work together at the G7
to help the populations hardest hit by
President Putin's war of choice
including by getting life-saving Aid to
the people most affected by the
unprecedented Global food crisis
and we'll continue to make crystal clear
that we and our NATO allies are prepared
to defend every inch of NATO territory
the United States and Canada are also
standing together and responding to
virtually every major Global challenge
that is having an effect on our people
just as we have for 150 years
Canada is a deeply valued Ally and
partner across the Arctic region in the
Arctic Council where we're working
together to promote sustainable economic
growth while also combating the climate
crisis in the coming weeks the United
States will release our Arctic strategy
to further these goals and we look
forward to continuing to work closely
with Canada to make them a reality
like the United States
Canada is both an Atlantic and Pacific
nation and we saw that last week at the
general assembly where Canada joined
both the partners in Blue Pacific and
the strengthening Atlantic cooperation
and ministerial meetings that we held
these initiatives will further our
shared goals of a prosperous resilient
and secure ocean region in both the
Atlantic and the Pacific
we're working together to end the HIV
aids malaria and tuberculosis epidemics
here too we saw Canada's leadership on
display at the general assembly with the
prime minister's exceedingly generous
contribution of more than 900 million
dollars to the global Fund in its
seventh replenishment
Canada Mexico and the United States are
Partners in the usmca
through which we're strengthening Supply
chains supporting strong labor rights
protections and accelerating the clean
energy transition across an increasingly
integrated North America
since December
our countries have partnered to mobilize
more than 294 million dollars in
international commitments for Haiti
we deeply appreciate Canada's leadership
in launching the UN basket fund to
improve citizen security and strengthen
law enforcement in Haiti an effort the
United States is proud to support
in these extremely difficult times for
the Haitian people we're urging more
partner Nations to contribute to this
vital cause
we also applaud Canada's leadership in
launching the Declaration against
arbitrary detention in state to state
relations
this is bringing Nations together to
send the clearest possible message that
the arbitrary Detention of foreign
Nationals is unacceptable and
governments that engage in this practice
will face consequences
we discuss ways to deepen what is an
already remarkably vibrant commercial
and trade relationship to boost our
Collective competitiveness to create
good paying jobs for people on both
sides of our border the United States
and Canada are of course already each
other's largest trading partners with
over 10 uh two billion dollars excuse me
in goods and services that pass between
us every single day but we know we can
do even more together to the benefit of
our people
one way to do that is through the
inflation reduction act which provides
more than 368 billion dollars for clean
energy Technologies like electric
vehicles and Battery components that are
manufactured in North America
it's the biggest most ambitious climate
investment in the history of our country
it offers a chance for us to deepen our
economic integration and expand
inclusive Economic Opportunity for our
people
another way is through the chips and
science Act
which will provide funds to develop
resilient semiconductor Supply chains in
North America which are crucial for so
many of the goods that we rely on from
smartphones to dishwashers to cars
our semiconductor Supply chains are
already deeply interconnected with
us-based companies like IBM and skyworks
conducting research development design
and packaging in Canada
it is hard to think of two countries
that work together as closely and across
as many areas as Canada and the United
States
and it's not only because our Fates and
interests are so closely intertwined but
it's because we approach these
challenges and opportunities from a
place of shared values
more than ever we are in this together
so Melanie as always thank you for the
visit but most important thank you for
your your partnership thank you for your
friendship uh on a professional level on
a personal level we're the closest of
collaborators and something I deeply
value and am grateful for every day it's
good to have you thank you thank you
Tony macedoni it's really a pleasure for
me to be here for my second visit to the
state department
um but before we start I would like also
to say a few words as Canadians are
observing the national day for Truth and
Reconciliation
we honor the children who never returned
home the survivors their families and
their communities path of reconciliation
is long and painful
it is one we must choose to walk with
indigenous peoples every day
canon in the United States and Secretary
of Lincoln mentioned share a special
unique relationship of course our two
countries are bound by geography and
history we're friends allies trading
partners because we know we are stronger
together when obviously we're standing
together
we invest in each other's successes
we have fought side by side on numerous
battlefields because our way of life our
democratic values or threatened
Vladimir Putin will stop at nothing to
consolidate his power and assert his
dominance
the vote to integrate Ukraine's
territories into the Russian Federation
is a crude attempt to formalize
presidents Putin's conquests through
political theater
as Canada and NATO allies have said the
pre-orchestrated outcomes of these
referenda have no legitimacy and will
never be recognized don't ask luhanks
Kirsten and zaparita will remain
Ukrainian territory
Canada has imposed sanctions today on 43
new oligarchs the so-called governing
body in kerson and 35 russian-backed
officials in vanesque luhans Kirsten and
zaporica
Canada is
courageous women across Iran are
currently in the streets protesting the
tragic killing of Masa amini kind of
salutes them and we want to say to
everybody that we stand with them in
saying that women's rights are human
rights
violations
to persecute the people this regime has
also shown a blatant disregard for human
life with flight ps752
Canada will sanction the so-called
morality police and its leadership and
Canada will hold Iran accountable for
its crime
as we fight for human rights secretary
blinken and I also discuss our effort to
strengthen International Peace and
security including through deepen
engagement in the indo-pacific
we share a vision of a free open and
inclusive indo-pacific region we both
believe in strengthening our diplomatic
and economic ties with the region and
the resiliency of our Global Supply
chains and the secretary just mentioned
about particularly the chips legislation
here and the initiative and obviously we
want to make sure that as the United
States go forward we also provide our
great expertise in in terms of critical
minerals in terms of extraction but also
Manufacturing
Canada is pleased to continue the the
work as a full member of the partnership
of the Blue Pacific alongside sacreton
Lincoln we were together at U.N general
assembly on the margins of the UN
General Assembly and to talk about this
very new initiative
now
several weeks ago President Biden spoke
to Americans at the Independence Hall in
Philadelphia
saying that democracy and equality are
under assault and that Americans are in
a battle for their soul for the soul of
their Nation
I know these words resonate deeply with
Canadians Canada is not immune to the
same threats to our democracy to rampant
this information on social media to
feelings of the stress towards our
institutions however are resolved in the
face of these challenges has never been
stronger
we will remain Resolute in our defense
of democracy and we will remain United
United in our vision for a more free and
Democratic World United in our pursuit
of a more just and equal society and
United in our determination to preserve
our institutions for future Generations
accomplished together
thank you we'll take our first question
from Sean Tandon with the AFP
hi hi there um thank you um to begin
with Mr secretary
thank you thank you very much thanks uh
could I follow up on a couple of items
today on Ukraine and Russia um to um uh
to both of you uh President Putin he
mentioned today he said that the West
Was to blame for uh what happened uh
Nordstrom I know the United States has
already rejected that uh do you have any
assessment of what actually happened uh
could this be a violation of could this
invoke Article Five uh for NATO uh and
uh what does it say about security of
the baltics uh is there a need to up the
security there uh and uh president
zielinski in response to uh in response
to what happened today uh called for
Fast Track membership uh into NATO do
you have any opinion on that do you
think that all countries should be in
NATO should be in board with that if I
could just follow up one thing the
foreign minister mentioned you mentioned
uh democracy uh Brazil has elections
coming on Sunday I wonder if the two of
you had any conversations about how to
approach that when to recognize the
results uh if there are any concerns
about preserving the uh the stability of
democracy and the Western hemisphere's
second most populous country thanks very
much
um Sean thank you uh first on the
pipelines
we've been in very close contact with
our partners in in Europe notably with
with Denmark and Sweden we are
supporting the investigation
into into these attacks on the pipelines
and working to be able to determine uh
who's responsible but I don't want to
get ahead of those investigations that
work is ongoing
um I think everyone by now is well aware
of something that Melanie alluded to
more more broadly but specific to Russia
which is the outrageous misinformation
and disinformation campaigns that it
engages in uh so um I really have
nothing to say to the Absurd
uh allegation from President Putin that
we or or
other partners or Allies are somehow
responsible for this uh but we will get
to the bottom
uh of what happened and we'll share that
information as soon as we're as soon as
we have it but I don't want to get ahead
of the investigation that's um that's
ongoing
with regard to uh uh to Nato and Ukraine
our position is and remains clear and
the same as it's been we strongly
support NATO's open door we strongly
support bringing into NATO
countries that seek to join and that can
add to NATO's capabilities there's a
process for doing that and countries
will continue to follow that that
process
um and then when it comes to Brazil and
the elections um
we're obviously not going to get into
another country's elections I can just
say uh generally speaking that um Brazil
has very strong
Democratic institutions including very
strong electoral institutions that
they've demonstrated time and time again
and we expect that that will be the case
in the in the upcoming election this
weekend
um to add to that obviously we support
NATO's and and the youth declaration
regarding the sabotage of the of the
pipelines we think that it is a very
important European infrastructure and
that is why I also had the opportunity
to talk to my Danish and Swedish
counterpart and obviously we spoke about
it as well
um regarding the referenda themselves
well you heard uh what I said regarding
this being Putin's political theater but
quite frankly no one is buying it so
we're reaching out with many countries
of the world to make sure as the U.N
Secretary General mentioned that it is
clear that this is against international
law and that we stand wrong against that
violation
regarding NATO so the Ukrainian section
to Nato our position has not changed it
has been the same which is essentially
we believe in NATO's open door policy
and we've always been in favor of
Ukraine exceeding to Nato and finally
regarding Brazil obviously my comments
are the same as as the secretary and the
sense that we will we will not meddle
into a Brazil's elections but what I can
say though is Tony and I will be heading
to the OS next week will be in Peru and
therefore we look forward to engaging
with uh we hope our our future
counterparts if that's the case and we
will obviously be having strong
discussions regarding the future of
democracy within our atmosphere
next let's go to James mccartan with the
Canadian press
thank you very much thank you both for
uh for doing this today um on the
subject of nordstream uh secretary and
Minister
regardless of responsibility obviously
uh the energy Supply situation in Europe
is is bad and only going to get worse as
a result of this I'm wondering if the
two of you spoke at all today about what
your two countries can do either
independently or collectively to help to
ease some of that pressure and is there
a heightened sense of danger in light of
that if we're talking about providing
supplies shipping supplies across the
ocean is it as simple as that or is it
more complicated now as a result of
these attacks
um I think first it's important to make
clear that these pipelines that is
Nordstrom water Nordstrom too we're not
pumping gas into Europe at this time
Nordstrom too never became operational
as is well known North stream one has
been shut down for weeks
because of Russia's weaponization of
energy
what we've been doing and we've also
been working on this together uh for
many many weeks as we saw the Russian
aggression in Ukraine and as we saw the
ongoing weaponization of energy by
Russia is to work very closely with
European Partners as well as countries
around the world to make sure that there
is enough energy on world markets and so
we've significantly increased our
production as well as making available
to Europe liquefied natural gas and
we're now the leading supplier of LNG to
Europe to help compensate for any gas or
oil that it's losing as a result of
Russia's aggression against Ukraine
we've worked to release oil from our
strategic petroleum Reserve to make sure
as well that there was oil on the
markets and to help keep prices down
we've engaged with the European Union
and established months ago a task force
to work directly with Europe on ways to
decrease demand to help get through the
winter as well as to pursue
additional Supply and to find ways to
speed up the transition to Renewables
even as we're getting through uh this uh
this challenging period so all of that
work is is ongoing
um
my own sense and I mentioned this the
other day is
look there's a lot of hard work to do to
make sure that countries and partners
get through the winter Europe itself has
taken very significant steps to both a
decreased demand but also look at ways
to
pursue the transition to Renewables at
the same time
and ultimately
this is also a tremendous opportunity
it's a tremendous opportunity to once
and for all remove the dependents on
Russian energy and thus to take away
from Vladimir Putin the weaponization of
energy is a means of advancing uh his uh
Imperial designs
that's very significant and that offers
tremendous
strategic opportunity for um for the
years to come but Meanwhile we're
determined to do everything we possibly
can to make sure that the consequences
of all of this are not borne by citizens
in our countries or for that matter
around the world
so to add that indeed we have increased
our production uh and therefore by
increasing our production we have
exported
um to the US for it to be
um to be eventually sent
um to to Europe
um Jonathan Wilkinson the minister of
Natural Resources have been in close
contact also with his counterpart on
this
um looking forward also where Canada can
really make a difference is through our
new kittimat LNG facility which will be
able to provide the LNG starting 2025
and therefore increasing production
lowering prices this will be also
helpful for European friends
and as mentioned when uh Chancellor
Schultz was in Canada
recently with also his vice Chancellor
we are also working
with the the Germans and and many other
European allies to find solutions for
the next years when it comes to
Renewables and the very important
significant investment in a hydrogen
facility in Stevensville Newfoundland is
part also of that plan so we want to be
either short-term with the existing
context we know we want to be there in
the middle term and we want to be there
in the long term we're obviously very
seized of the energy security situation
in Europe and that's why we're in
solution mode
Joel Gerke Washington Examiner
I thank you both for doing this I'm
going to begin with a question on Iran
and then turn to Ukraine
Mr secretary Amnesty International says
that Collective action is the quote
Collective action by the International
Community that goes beyond statements of
condemnation end quote is needed to Halt
the violent suppression of protests in
Iran and now an American citizen has
been killed in Iraq as the state
department has confirmed and the irgc
has used ballistic missiles and other
ordinance in a series of strikes in Iraq
does the U.S have a response to that
Beyond statements of condemnation
um on on Ukraine we saw this week a
senior Ukrainian intelligence officials
said there's a very high risk of that
Russia will use a tactical nuclear
weapon in some fashion
his recommendation in light of that was
to call for uh anti-rocket systems from
the U.S
do you think that there is uh are there
weapons the U.S can provide to mitigate
the threat of a tactical Nuclear Strike
do you think that the prudent response
to such a nuclear threat is to attempt
to deter by upgrading Ukrainian
armaments or to keep U.S military aid
below some threshold that might be
provocative
and then of course
Canada and the United States both
participated in the Copenhagen
conference last month which was focused
on how to provide long-term support to
the ukrainians we are apparently
settling in for a longer a long much
longer conflict than than maybe anybody
expected as you consider the options for
long-term support
do you do you think that the West needs
to help Ukraine transition to training
on more advanced NATO systems be those
tanks or fighter jets or anything else
or should the focus be more on
financial support perhaps for increasing
defense capacity in defense industrial
production and you know the Czech
Republic and other places that can
produce russian-style Legacy equipment
that they've been more familiar with
thank you
there's a lot there that's more than one
question actually oh boy
um Let me let me take a stab at it first
um Melanie and then and then turn to you
first on Iran
um starting with the protests um the
simple truth is this
masamini should be alive right now
uh and
her death in and of itself
is a profound affront to human rights in
Iran and for that matter uh everywhere
when we see the Iranian government
firing on Peaceful protesters
um then cutting off people's access
to the global internet uh we're not only
watching this we're taking action in
response
you saw some of the actions that we've
taken already
we designated the so-called morality
police
uh the institution responsible for her
death as well as seven other Iranian
security officials involved in human
rights abuses
at the same time
and we talked about this earlier in the
week the treasury Department issued new
licenses that will facilitate the
provision of communications equipment
software and Hardware to Iranians to
allow them to better communicate amongst
themselves and also with the rest of the
world and all of this is is ongoing
we'll continue to look for ways to
support those who are engaging and
expressing themselves peacefully in Iran
as well as taking actions against those
who are responsible for the most
repressive human rights violations that
one can imagine there's also a growing
course of condemnation around the world
including an international institution
something that the foreign minister and
I discussed today with regard to the
rocket attacks that took place
first and foremost this was an assault
on Iraqi sovereignty which we've seen
again and again coming from Iran we're
supporting our Iraqi and our Kurdish
Partners in the face of this aggression
you've of course seen International
condemnation of Iran's uh actions
including from the Iraqi government
itself
and we've always been clear that Iran
cannot and will not act with uh with
impunity we've demonstrated that we are
willing to use a wide array of tools at
our disposal to counter Iran's malign
and destabilizing activities in the
region we've done that in the past and
as necessary we'll continue to do that
in the future this includes sanctions it
includes other Financial measures and
includes diplomatic pressure we've used
every tool in our Arsenal as necessary
and when it comes to it President Biden
has not hesitated to act to protect our
citizens as well as our service members
from Attack so we're monitoring the
situation very closely and of course for
coordinating with our partners
especially in the region
when it comes to the
rhetoric we've heard from President
Putin on nuclear weapons you heard us
speak to this very directly at the
United Nations this week
this kind of loose talk about nuclear
weapons is the height of
irresponsibility
and it's something that
we take very seriously we are looking
very carefully to see if Russia is
actually doing anything
that suggests that they are
contemplating the use of nuclear weapons
to date we've not seen them take
these actions but we also know that uh
Russia is engaged in horrific
a horrific brutalization of Ukraine and
so the threats that they make
we we take very seriously as to
President Putin's intent I'm not going
to speculate on what's in his mind I can
just tell you that we we plan against
every possible scenario including this
one
um as to the long-term support for
Ukraine
this is a very important question and a
couple of things are
I think worth underscoring
one is at every step along the way
um
in the Russian aggression against
Ukraine we have worked to make sure that
we are getting to the ukrainians what
they need to effectively defend
themselves against the aggression that
started before the aggression as you
know as we saw it possibly coming even
as we were trying to do everything we
could to stop it to prevent it we were
working to help prepare the ukrainians
for the aggression and working with
allies and partners to do that going
back a year ago Labor Day of a year ago
the president did his first drawdown of
Defense equipment to Ukraine we did
another significant one just before
Christmas again well before the Russian
aggression that put into Ukrainian hands
the very things that they needed and
used so effectively Stingers javelins to
repel the aggression directed achieve in
the attempt to take over the whole
country that failed in large part
because of the the courage of the
Ukrainian people but also because we
help them get ready now since then what
we've been doing is making sure that we
adapt and adjust as the nature of the
aggression changes to make sure that
they have what they need but not only
have what they need that that they can
use it effectively and maintain it
increasingly you're seeing NATO standard
systems going to to Ukraine to deal with
the ongoing Russian aggression
part of that is training and there's
training that's happening right now
outside of Ukraine to make sure that as
we provide these systems to them they
are able to effectively use them and I
think going forward
what Ukraine wants and needs is a strong
defensive and deterrence system that
makes it less likely in the future that
Russia will act aggressively toward
Ukraine and that if it does nonetheless
do that that Ukraine is very well
prepared so even as we're working in the
moment to make sure that they have what
they need right now we're also working
with them on the medium in the long term
to make sure that they have what they
need to have effective defense and
effective deterrence against Russia I'm
not going to get into the details of of
what that involves but it is a very
important question that we're acting on
right now
so commence a long answer I guess
um so on Iran uh of course Canada is
standing up with the strong woman of
Iran that are peacefully protesting in
the streets of Tehran and across the
territory that is why also I mentioned
our steadfast support to them when I was
at the UN General Assembly and I I gave
the national address for Canada
um that is why also we are sanctioning
the so-called morality police like the
U.S is doing and key leaders of that
morality police but I must say that a
lot of things are on the table and we've
done a lot but we need to do more and
we'll do more
um also Canada has been spearheading the
a U.N resolution before the general
assembly and making sure that we condemn
Iran's human rights violations in
general and so that is why we'll
continue to offer and and present that
leadership before the UN
um
alongside many nations obviously with
the US
um
on the question of
Ukraine in general of course on the and
particularly the question of nuclear
threats you've heard the secretary
you've heard Jan stoltenberg ahead of
NATO
and many of us say nobody wins when it
comes to nuclear so obviously this is
Unthinkable
but we have to be ready and we are
having conversations particularly within
the G7 on this very issue
on also the question of whether this the
referendas and this
so-called annexation by Russia of
territories obviously we do not
recognize it we do not want to give any
form of legitimacy to it and therefore
this won't change our military strategy
and so that is why we'll continue to
send weaponry and I would say mainly
where Canada's actually expertise is is
training of Ukrainian officers we have
done that since 2014 before the war we
had trained already 30 000 Ukrainian
soldiers and so we are partnering with
the UK on this and we are training out
of the UK many of the Ukrainian officers
final question Alex Panetta CV CBC News
I just wanted to ask a quick follow-up
on two of the things that came up
earlier in this news conference and the
SI Vu puriere
so the first one involves nato in the
accession process
when Sweden and Finland applied earlier
this year it proceeded with lightning
speed would you anticipate that Ukraine
would move that quickly through this
process or given the level of complexity
and risk involved are we talking years
rather than months in this particular
case and the second is on on Eastern uh
Ukraine the Weapons Systems that NATO
countries are providing to Ukraine we
can infer from your earlier answer that
nothing will change in the way the the
war proceeds in eastern Ukraine but
could I ask you whether there are any
instructions any different instructions
about whether or not Western weapon
systems can be used on Eastern Ukrainian
territory thank you
foreign
Finland and Sweden as you know these are
the these countries were both very long
time uh NATO partners that in many ways
have been de facto allies for a long
long time working in very close
coordination with NATO having very
Advanced militaries that are fully
interoperable already with NATO
with
equipment that is also fully compatible
with what NATO countries have and of
course strong democracies that have been
Partners as part of the European Union
and uh and with us for many many many
years so I think that that explains the
rapidity with which this process has
moved forward
um when it comes to
the
aggression in eastern Ukraine uh and uh
and Southern Ukraine and but
particularly now the purported
annexation of territory
um we have been
very clear about this and as you just
heard uh Melanie repeat it has no
validity No legitimacy no legal standing
this territory remains Ukraine's it will
always be a part of Ukraine we will
never recognize the purported annexation
of this territory and as I said
Ukraine has every right
to defend all of its territory to defend
the people who are there and to take
back territory that was illegally seized
from it in the first place and our
support to Ukraine uh will continue uh
and that support can be used as uh as
Ukraine sees fit
um throughout the country
to defend its territory and is necessary
to take it back
so regarding Sweden and Finland
obviously we value the fact that they
joined NATO we were the first country in
the world to ratify the accession
because there are also Arctic countries
it was in Canada's interests to speed up
ratification
and as I mentioned before
we believe that Ukraine should be part
of NATO it's been our position for now
more than a decade and we believe in the
open door policy
in French
[Music]
regarding the question of whether this
will change our military strategy how
how will we react I've answered that
question uh clearly like like the
secretary like Tony mentioned
we do not recognize Putin's words he's
spreading lies again this is part of
political theater nobody is buying it
and so that's why we will not change the
course of our actions and that's why we
will continue to work with the us on
this and all our European counterparts
and and definitely we need to continue
to do more
as I said in English
[Music]
foreign